hey what's up guys my name is a cha know
and this video is basically just here to
let you guys know that i will be doing a
lot of their 27 this weekend ok so
that's pretty much out of the way now
let me go over the logistics of stuff so
first of all it starts 11am australian
eastern standard time might best in
daylight I'm I don't think it is there
wait I don't know anyway so it starts at
11am for me when it sells for you if you
want to find out loud and data comm port
that combo and link is in the
description there's like a countdown to
it ok so that's when I will start
streaming maybe about 15 minutes prior
where will I be streaming because I will
be live streaming the entire event as I
pretty much do every time I duel under
i'll be live streaming it at twitch.tv
for / the churner again the link is in
the description just hang around
bookmark that page keep refreshing it if
i'm offline i'll probably too unless i
go to bed or something i'll i'll be
streaming pretty much the entire
development so just hang around there
and on and you'll find me and the other
thing is I've been fixing up the website
a lot because what happens is I I
frequently change like my CMS system for
my website and everything and what
happens is paths kind of get corrupt and
everything so that ye you won't be able
to play like my path won their games are
download the source code I'm going to
fix all that because I've been meaning
to for a while so the official I guess
site for playing playing this because i
will be uploading copies as i go along
with adam dare so in other words i'll
what once i get like alpha download the
beta dental just pop it up so you guys
can play it or whatever it was
previously under entries and the source
code to this one because of course it
will be open source every lavender entry
has to be open sores all that you'll
find on the channel calm ok so I've
revamped that entire site specifically
the channel calm for / LD okay full /
LDL d stands for love them dear that'll
be the UM side you can view there's like
a list that's like a menu where you can
select which I let them do you want to
view and a lot under 27 is the one
that's going to be this weekend and yeah
so basically if you just go to the chair
no calm for / ld4 / 27 link will be in
the description that's what i'll upload
stuff probably so I'm be sure to check
that out it should be it should be
pretty awesome but otherwise i'll see
you guys on twitch.tv false after the
turner
tomorrow at 11am for me again if you
want to know exactly want to start
streaming I will tweet this by the way
so twitter.com for / the Jenner um and
i'll post on facebook so facebook com
for / the Jonah pretty much everywhere
and i will post a video on youtube even
and you can follow me on twitter TV and
and the countdown to the competition is
on load and datacom for / compare i'll
see you guys there goodbye